first of all are you guys both doing
okay really good yeah I'm excited that
this thing is finally coming out yeah is
it some true or not true questions true
or not true that you took the gig
because you wanted to spend a few weeks
geeking out about breaking bed ah true
true or not true for you you did the
movie because the producers said that in
every scene you're drinking you would be
allowed to have Pappy Van Winkle
oh very true yeah right this is what I
was talking about so Aaron mentioned to
me about Pappy a few years ago and and
he opened the door to something terrible
because it's very difficult to get yeah
yeah yeah if I can find it you know yeah
well if I remember correctly you
mentioned your producer on Bojack yeah
every time you get picked up gives you a
bottle he does yeah yeah my producing
partner
Bojack every year he comes with the
Pappy 23 I don't know I'm spoiled
have you gotten it this year I have yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah okay so when can you
let us know when you're having that
party that people can actually try this
I come I mean I brought some with me oh
of course
yeah yeah right um yeah so jumping into
I get to talk to you guys um one of the
things this movie plays on I think a lot
of people's fears myself included that
you rent something and you really never
know what you're gonna get you know I've
always when I do Airbnb I'm always like
did they set up like I think about these
things in this movie just f'd with me
yeah yeah so for the two of you talk a
little bit about that aspect of the film
I mean you're just joking around about
this earlier but I actually never really
thought about that until after shooting
this movie now I can't stop thinking
about it
it's like it would be so easy because
you're going inside someone else's
property so they can hide really cameras
anyway which is terrifying I mean I
stayed at an Airbnb once where they had
these weird like plastic animal masks on
the breakfast nook and we left for an
hour and we came back and there
different masks there on the breakfast
nook you know so thanks yeah we want
right this is very odd yeah yeah yeah I
mean listen I love Airbnb I love like
any I think it's always like the best
way to travel instead of going to hotel
like live in the place but definitely I
mean I think just in general like we
forget how watched we are in the only 18
like we're being watched all the time
and you know when you get in someone
else's car you get in someone else's
house like it's important to remember
that and you know this is a whole new
kind of avenue of thriller that I like
which is why I like it yeah yeah also I
don't want to talk about spoilers but um
I like that the third act has a little
bit more going on than maybe people are
expecting so I'm curious when you guys
and again I don't want to spoil anything
but when you guys were reading the
script how much when you when you get a
script like that how much are they
telling you what the movie is and about
the twists and turns and how much are
they saying someone telling you hey just
read the script let me know what you
think yeah yeah that's exactly what for
me the script you know landed on my desk
and I just I knew that she was she had
already attached herself and and so I I
read it right away and I just love the
the ride that you know we go on and it's
a it starts kind of quiet and then
there's just a lot of twists and turns
and then it just really ramps up in a in
a kind of crazy one crazy way yeah I
just like that the expectations are like
is this some weird like romantic drama
yeah like what is like do we even care
about these people and like all of the
things that you sort of think could
happen which is like you know Aaron's
character becoming jealous or some of
the things that are kind of led down
they're all dead ends and then this like
really kind of unexpected turn happens
and I think that all of the expectations
are the characters are sort of switched
I would imagine that once you agreed
that you wanted to do it and you both
involved that first meeting has to be a
little bit nerve-wracking because you're
a feeling each other out too
are we compatible like how our
personalities and be can we have the
Kemp you know what I mean there's all
that stuff that has to be figured out so
for the two of you talk a little bit
that about that first meeting how
nervous were each of you or do you get
nervous before a meeting like that well
Aaron's the best just to be I'm gonna
jam and literally just invited me to his
house to like come to a party so it was
actually a great way to meet someone
I've to interject did he offer you Pappy
because he's not which now I'm really
pissed about but I actually spilled red
wine on his carpet did you on our first
meeting yeah and I was like hi Lauren
Emily I've stained your carpet can you
help me um anyway uh no it was he really
like made it so great for both of us and
you know then we were in Italy together
yeah I god I mean it was it was amazing
you know it was just an embarrassment of
riches then you know after we hung out
at the house we was it was the reading
before or after that reading was after
that today yeah so we sat down and read
the script with our director and writer
and some of the producers and it was
just you know got it on its feet and I
just felt so natural and comfortable and
fun yeah my big question is I was just
in Italy like a week ago and I was there
for like two days yeah I think I put on
five pounds yeah my question is you guys
filmed there for weeks
oh yeah did you not put on like 10 or 20
pounds from I did put on no we did yeah
yeah I liked watch cuz we actually were
lucky to shoot the movie kind of
sequentially which is really amazing
that never happened so I'm like watching
it in the movie I'm like the first part
I'm like AHA there I am and then by the
end of my yeah but I like it whatever it
was whatever so I mean we had pasta
every single day yeah like two meals a
day yeah it was great and also the thing
that a lot of people might not realize
is I don't know are you guys red wine
drinkers yes very much
see I am too and the problem is that in
Italy there's the table wine in Italy is
insanely good yeah and they have it at
every meal well the house we shot out is
Winery yeah we were we weren't done
right so you paid to be in the movie
they yeah yeah exactly
basically yeah right I mean it's crazy
though yeah when you think back on Italy
though and filming there what's like the
day is you're a day or two that you will
always remember a lot of days to be
honest yeah one day Oh either or I mean
on set I was just talking about this
earlier but in this in this movie
there's a whole outside of the villa
I was dug and they found a dead body
while shooting and they had to kind of
shut down production hearing old a very
like the body was there for hundreds and
hundreds of years so it's just a
skeleton now sure but it is still very
you know one of our pas actually was
like scooped up shove a full of dirt and
just like kind of turned a a jaw of a
skull and it's just yeah so I remember
that there's no way it's week five like
I got any pranks now yeah um that's
crazy and I've not heard that story
about like a memorable I asked a lot
about memorable moments I've never been
historic yeah yeah that one stands out
yeah sure
you